soit philippe froguel mais beaucoup
d'être avec nous en direct sur arte
france on va essayer de voix là dedans
savoir un petit peu plus sur ce variant
ce nouveau variant qui nous fait peur un
double mutants pourquoi le qualifier
ainsi
alors vous avez déjà expliqué ça très
très bien j'ai pas grand chose à dire de
plus c'est parce que les
caractéristiques des variants brésilien
sud africain mais aussi californien qui
sont des variantes qui sont plus
contagieux et qui pourrait entraîner une
résistance à l'immunité qu'elle soit
naturelle des gens qui ont déjà fait la
couv id ou qui ont été vaccinés et donc
c'est pour ça que c'est très inquiétant
ce qui est affreux or en inde c'est la
rapidité d'explosions et de deux
nouveaux cas notamment à côté de bombay
puisque passé en très très peu de jours
à plusieurs centaines de milliers de
personnes qui ont été diagnostiqués
problème beaucoup plus une autre chose
droit qui m'a affolés et qui est mal
connue il ya eu un avion qui est parti
de bombay pourront khouya ya quelques
jours il a maintenant dix jours et
personne n'était positif au départ et à
l'arrivée
mais les chinois de hong kong sont
prudents ils ont mis en joue les 188
personnes les ont mis en quarantaine
pendant 12 jours et il y en a eu près de
la moitié de l'avion qui était positif
annoncé 12 jours on est vraiment dans
une situation de quelque chose d'hyper
contagieux qui peut peut-être apparaître
tardivement déjà c'était un peu le cas
pour le variés anglais et si les
français font pas des choses sérieuses
comme on le fait en angleterre ça risque
de compromettre complètement le plan
vaccinal et de libération de du
confinement des présidents macron
effectivement le royaume uni vous faites
bien de le souligner qui restera un les
vols en provenance du pays à ses seuls
résidents depuis le 19 avril
clairement ce qu'on semble le faire en
france imposé une quarantaine sané
pas suffisant selon vous il faut prendre
des mesures drastiques comme le font les
britanniques
il faut vraiment vraiment très prudent
voire interdire les personnes qui
viennent d'inde soit directement soit
indirectement à rta qu'à travers la riaa
airways par exemple comme s'arrêtant à
qatar ou via dubai et si des personnes
viennent notamment des français et bien
il faut il ya plein de dhôtel vide à
roissy et orly
il faut vraiment faire passer jours
c'est chez pearson les pistes et au
moins 2 à 3 fois et ciseaux positif
faire le séquençage complet parce que il
faut vraiment être sûr qu'il s'agit d'un
nouveau variant nous on va le tester et
la semaine prochaine à reims
non on sera dans la fin de la semaine
prochaine si c'est déjà arrivé en france
on a eu des échantillons aujourd'hui je
pense qu'on va ce vendredi on saura
c'est même déjà quelques-uns on va
surveiller ça de très près dans les
hauts de france mais je peux vraiment
mettre en garde le gouvernement hier
j'ai prévenu olivier veyrat qui avait
l'air inquiet mais c'est paris jusqu'à à
limiter les voyages vannes en inde
il faut bien comprendre que toute la
politique française vaccination
progressive à la vitesse où on peut et
de libération aux principes de la vie
économique et sociale va être impossible
si on a une arrivée des variants d'abord
brésilien et puis des variants indien en
france à se retrouver une situation qui
sera ingérable
justement le 5 le séquençage on vous en
parlait le royaume uni on le sait le
pratiquent beaucoup on a quelques
faiblesses en france ça s'améliore note
de ce point de vue là non en fait ça
fait mailhiot report c'est un petit peu
comme la pcr il ya exactement un an les
services de virologie laissant nationaux
de référence pasteur pense que et 10
partout qu'ils font mais en réalité on
n'a pas plus de deux à trois mille
séquence complète qui sont mises en est
pas de données ne t'ont pas analysé
puisque mr de la recherche
vidal n'a pas mis en place des
structures de recherche
il nous permettait de savoir quoi faire
notamment de pouvoir avoir de nouveaux
vaccins ou vraiment de réagir mieux dans
ce cas on vous donner un exemple qui
date d'aujourd'hui est un ehpad d'un an
dans les hauts de france avec des
personnes qui ont été vaccinées kaiser
ils sont quand même infecté eh bien il
ya deux semaines l'agencé régionale de
santé à redemander d'envoyer gens qui
ont positif à pasteur paris il n'a
jamais répondu et donc qu'il nous
apporte demain pour que moi lille le
fasse le travail on aurait dû être fait
c'est pas normal ce genre de choses et
comme comme un tas d'autres d'ailleurs
mais malheureusement en ce moment
philippe froguel quand on vous écoute et
qu'on est un petit peu novice on n'est
pas scientifique comme vous on se dit
c'est quoi c'est la vie normale d'un
virus et variant qui deviennent de plus
en plus contagieux qui deviennent de
plus en plus dangereux ou c'est
spécifique à ce virus là locaux vides 19
et moi je suis un généticien et comme
tout généticien connaissant la rn ça je
sais que ça me fout tous mes collègues
virologues pendant près de neuf points
on dit vous inquiétez pas ça va pas 8 et
6 5 minutes c'est pas important ça
m'avait toujours un peu surpris hélas à
la sauver et là j'avais raison d'être
pessimiste et c'est pour ça que dès le
mois de décembre je suis vraiment
mobiliser parce que emule et dans des
formes qui sont plus dangereuses
et comme en france on a une circulation
virale très important on a des airs et
risque important d'avoir un virus
français aussi aussi dangereux que
l'indien et permet vaccination est lente
et bien on n'est pas dans la
civilisation britannique où ils ont
jugulé à la levée anglais et bravo et je
pense pas qu'ils vont réussir j'espère à
juguler l'indien à condition de ne pas
se retrouver effectivement avec des
variants un bien qui les envahissent
trop puisqu'on a bien compris qu'il
était davantage résistant aux vaccins
semble-t-il
merci philippe froguel en tout cas
d'avoir été avec nous nous avons apporté
votre précieuse analyse mr
à vous